[Music]
for
Christian
[Music]
are we on
okay well welcome everybody we're so
glad to see you all we're glad to see
all you guys online too as well uh
welcome to this beautiful place that
we're now meeting and uh wanted to let
you know that um we have a class coming
up it's called The Welcome to the table
class and it is going to be held next
Sunday March the 3 so if you're new here
or if you're curious about who we are or
you want to find out more about our
story uh maybe you'd like to even become
a member of the table then this class is
for you
and so that class will be next Sunday
March the 3rd at 3:00 it'll last till
4:30 uh here at first sexy and the child
care will be provided so sign up using
the QR code or you can fill out a card
on the little table over here to the
right and drop it in that little brown
box uh got to save the date for you this
is an important one for you so save the
date for Saturday evening March the 30th
because we'll be celebrating Easter that
night uh instead of Sunday morning and
that also will be right here at uh Saxy
first Brett is off this evening so
tonight we have the joy of having the
Reverend Denise Mason with us she's the
yeah uh she's the pastor at Pleasant
Valley United Methodist Church and is
someone that our community always enjoys
hearing
from okay so now let's uh prepare
ourselves for
worship let's just quiet our
[Music]
minds we open our
hearts we prepare our hearts and our
minds to meet Jesus here in this loving
Community we give you praise and thanks
thanks for giving us this day and for
this worship
time so let us just take a moment to be
still and to know God's love is for
[Music]
us
that's so
[Music]
weird the trick will be getting it to
come through my in
[Laughter]
ears
I
do okay awesome thank you trying to turn
this one off so that it
doesn't sorry about that guys okay
restart do you guys want to stand up
with us you're going to need to for this
song I know everything feels like
peaceful and quiet right this second but
it's about to not feel peaceful and
quiet so that's your warning
okay we're to learn a new song it's
called there's nothing left to
do it's by uh a band that has just been
really helpful for me because it gives
great context for like sort of real life
and what we're going through and this
one in particular just I I went to my
Bible this morning and looked up
Jeremiah 29 and you guys know that verse
that says um I know the plans that I
have for you declares the Lord plans to
prosper you plans to give you a hope and
a future not plans to harm you and then
you will call on me and I will answer
you then I will be found by you um so I
want us to just go into this song with
that in mind that there is this God of
the universe this Creator who is
constantly looking for ways to give us
hope to bring us hope he believes in us
he is with us he is for us um so we're
going to learn this a little bit like if
any of you went to Youth Camp back in
the day I hope that for for some of you
that might be like uh I'm out of
here for me I I had some positive
experiences with youth camp and um so
that's that's the spirit in which I say
that is a good positive like Yay
everybody's singing and everybody's
clapping and having fun together um so I
want to teach us a couple parts to this
new song so if you guys would just like
like what is it called just like flatter
me just indulge indulge that's the word
I'm like what's what's there's another
better word for that if yall will just
indulge us and sing along it's there's a
slow part that we're going to learn and
then there's a fast part and just for
Giggles Katlyn is on slides today I
really got Jesse I'm I'm sorry I'm sorry
sometimes I say the wrong words Kaitlyn
made this amazing slide that's going to
be super helpful for you guys when we
got get to the fast part okay just
follow a line on the slides and you will
be good to go okay so all right
um let's start on this bridge
okay it's going to say we find all we
are in your loving arms so let's as you
catch on just sing it along with us
[Music]
okay here we
go we find all we are in your loving
arms we find all we are in
youring arms sing it out we find all we
are in
your arms again we find all we are in
your Ling
arms and now here comes the fast part
all right get
ready there is a do but run into your
arms where I am broken I am ruined I am
lost but I do not there is nothing left
to do but run into your arms I am broken
I am ruined I am lost got it is left
into your arms I am broken I am ruined I
am lost I do die there is nothing left
to do but run into your arms for I am
broken I am ruined I am Lo do not nice
there is no Haven
there is no high
way there is no safe
place outside of you no shelter there is
no
shelter there is no
refuge there is no
refuge outside of you all right here we
go there is nothing left to do but run
into your arm broken I am ruined I am
lost if I do not there is nothing left
to do run into your arms for I am broken
I am ruined iost
again I am broken I am ruined I
amost your
rock
[Music]
Rin there is no
hope there is no
future there is no
Freedom outside of
you there is no
joy there's no
salvation there is no
living outside of
you here we go there is nothing left to
do but run into your arms for I am
broken I am ruined I am lost if I do not
there is nothing left to do but run into
your arms for I am broken I am ruined I
am lost if I do not there is nothing run
to your rock I am broken I am ruined I
am there is nothing do run to your ARS I
am broken I am ruined I am lost but
do all right let's sing we find we find
all we are in your Ling arms we find all
we are in your loving arms we find all
we are in your loveing arms we find all
we are in your Ling arms we find all we
are in your love
[Music]
arms we find all we are in
your last time we find all we are in
your Ling arms we find all we are in
your
Ling
Liv all right good job you guys y'all
are good sports I know that's definitely
high energy and we tend to be a
sometimes introverted
Bunch but I like kicking it off with
some
fun all right kiddos if y'all would
follow your teachers to that door
they're waiting for you over there and
they will take you to your
classrooms thank you guys for being with
us it's hard for you guys to guess who
might be the class clowns in those
groups very
difficult all right we're going to
transition into the prayers of the
people um you guys have I think most of
you have been with us before but um if
y'all would read this aloud with us and
then we're going to leave space for you
to share what you may be carrying on
your heart whether it's a person or a
situation that's heavy on your heart
today would you just speak that out into
this space and we're going to hold it
before God together and then we'll we'll
finish the prayer together after
that for this city of Saxy Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you Lord we know that
you hear us and that you love us so we
lift these names and situations up to
[Music]
you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen
I've carried a
birden for too long on my
own I was in create
it to Bear it
alone I hear your
invitation to let it all
go I see it now I'm laying it down and I
know that I need you I run to the father
I fall into Grace I'm done with the
hiding no reason to wait my heart needs
a Sur my soul needs a friend so I run to
the father again and again and again and
again
[Music]
oh
you saw my
condition had a plan from the
start your son for
[Music]
Redemption the price for my
heart and I don't have a
context for that kind of love I don't
understand I can't
comprehend all I know is I
need you run to the father I falling to
Grace I'm done with the hiding no reason
to wait my heart needs a Sur my soul
needs a friend so I run to the father
again and again and again and
again
oh
oh again and
again
oh my heart has been in your side
long before my first
breath running
into your arms is running to life
from death and I feel this Rush deep in
my chest his Mercy is
calling out just as I am
you pull me in and I know I need you now
I run to the father I fall into Grace
I'm done with the high no reason to wait
my heart needs a Sur my soul needs a
friend so I run to the father again and
again I run to the father fall into
Grace I'm done with the hiding no reason
to wa my heart found a surge my soul
found a friend so I run to the father
again and again and again and
again
oh
oh and again and again and
[Music]
again and again and
again
[Music]
I'm caught up in your
presence I just want to sit here at your
feet I'm caught up in this
whole
moment I never want
[Music]
oh I'm not here for
blessings Jesus you don't hold me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just want
[Music]
you and I'm
Sor when I've just gone through the
motions I'm
sorry when I just sing another song take
me back to where we
start I open up my
heart to you
and I'm
sorry when I've come with my
agenda I'm
sorry when I forgot that you're enough
take me back to where we
started I open up my
heart to
you
I'm caught up in your
presence I just want to sit here at your
feet I'm caught up in this
holy
[Music]
moment I never want to
leave
oh I'm not here for
blessing Jesus you don't owe me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just want
[Music]
you and I just want
you and nothing
else and nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want
you and nothing
else and nothing
else nothing else will
do what just want
you nothing
else nothing
else nothing else will
do I just want you and nothing
else and nothing else
Jesus nothing else will
[Music]
do
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing else will
do
Jesus nothing else will
[Music]
W I'm caught up in your
presence I just want to see here at your
feet I'm caught up in this
[Music]
ho
moment I never want to
leave oh I'm not here for bless
BL Jesus you don't know me
anything more than
anything that you can
do I just want
[Music]
you
God we want to run back to
you back to our
source our
creator the one who loved
us from the
beginning the one who still loves us now
today just as we
are
[Music]
God we run back to the
love of a
savior the love of a
[Music]
friend not a love that manipulates or
shames us
not a love that has waited for us to get
it right or get it
together but a love that is
steady
steadfast
[Music]
unconditional a love that wraps its arms
around us when we are broken when we are
hurting when we are ugly
a love who sees the beauty that it
began long
[Music]
ago and calls it
back come
home we want to return to
you in this season of LM
as we are more aware of our own
[Music]
shortcomings the mess that we are in God
I pray that we would hear your voice
calling us
back help us to
return in Jesus
name
amen would you guys turn to the people
around you and make them feel welcomed
in at home and then Denise is going to
come up and get us started on our
message thank you so
much well I want to First just say how
great grateful I am to be back with you
all I always uh love coming to preach
before you all because you you're just
so receptive and just wonderful people
and I'm just grateful to that Brett
gives me this chance um and so thank you
for having me this evening um at your
wonderful new facility which is just
really exciting isn't it so the
scripture that I wanted to preach off to
uh preach out of today comes from the
gospel of St Matthew I'm afraid I'm
going to knock something over so I'm
just trying to be really careful here
comes from from the gospel of St Matthew
it is chapter 16 and it's pretty short
it's verses 13 and uh I think it goes up
to 15 I say I think because I didn't
write down the verse numbers but I think
it's 13 through 15 so he now these
words now when Jesus came into the
District of cesari Philippi he said to
his disciples or he asked his disciples
who do people say that the son of man is
and they said some say John the Baptist
but others say Elijah and still others
Jeremiah are one of the
prophets he said to them but who do you
say I
am Simon Peter answered you are the
Messiah the Son of the Living God and
Jesus answered him blessed are you Simon
son of Jonah for flesh and blood has not
revealed this to you but my Father in
heaven and I tell you you are Peter and
on this rock I will build my church and
the gates of Hades will not Prevail
against
it this is God's word for God's people
this evening thanks be to God would you
pray with
me come Holy Spirit Come May the words
of my mouth and the meditations of our
hearts be acceptable in your sight our
Rock and Our
Redeemer
amen so I have a colored portrait of
myself that I keep in my office at all
time uh it was drawn by a little girl in
a congregation where I was appointed to
before I came to Pleasant Valley and she
drew it one day while I she was sitting
in church and she brought it to me and
if you have the
slide there it is right
there and I just loved it she said here
Pastor n Denise everyone says it looks
just like you from your hair down to
your
shoes now I love the picture but I have
to say I hope she was wrong about the
eyes because they're kind of scary now
this past Christmas I received another
drawn portrait of myself and this time
it was from my granddaughter Lily and
she mailed it to me from uh Atlanta and
this is the picture she sent to me now I
immediately called her to thank her and
I said Lily I'm so this is so wonderful
thank you for sending this picture but
why do I have such red lips she said I
don't know that's just the way your lips
are nana I I guess that's just the way
God Made You So apparently my my lips
are an important part of me but clothes
seem to be an optional
Choice I'm just saying now these
portraits are really special to me
primarily of because of who drew them
right but they're also special to me
because they each portray a unique
picture of me it's not me as I see
myself it's me as they see me to one
person I'm a red-haired pastor with
black black boots and to another I'm a
hopefully not naked Nana with red lips
now if you were to ask my kids when they
were little well they'd have a very
different opinion of who I am I remember
one time my youngest daughter was in my
lap and she was telling me some story
and her sister walked in and promptly
tried to crawl up and sit with me on my
uh sit on my lap with her sister well
this didn't go over too well and there
was much weeping and nashing of teeth
and the youngest finally pushed her
sister off saying and shouted no this is
my mommy no she's not the other said
she's my mommy uhuh she's my mommy and
it went on and on and then as I was
trying to get him to stop while my
husband walked in and he goes girls
you're both wrong she's my mommy oh you
would have thought both girls
immediately stopped screaming and they
stared at him and they go no they're
she's not Dad she's not your mommy she's
your
boss for the record they were mostly
right I got to tell
you the way others perceive us has a lot
to do with who they think we are doesn't
it I mean our relationship or our lack
of relationship with them our Authority
or lack of authority over them our
visibility or lack of visibility our
abilities to help our Tendencies to take
well they all play a vital role in how
others Define us how they treat us how
they respect us or disrespect us talk to
us or talk about us who am I well the
question really depends on who you ask
doesn't
it this is the focus for our text for
today taken from the gospel of St
Matthew and it begins with the words now
when Jesus came into the District of
cesare Philippi he asked his disciples
who do others say the son of man is is
now it's an interesting question but
it's made even more interesting by the
place in which Jesus asked this question
you see he had just entered this
District of cesaria Philippi and it's a
largely Gentile City that's home to a
large Temple dedicated to the worship of
Caesar against this backdrop of worldly
power well Jesus asks a pretty
penetrating
question who do people say that I
am now the answers that are given are
even more interesting really well some
say John the Baptist and others say
Elijah some say Jeremiah or one of the
prophets now it's obvious that Elijah
Jeremiah and the other prophets had been
dead a long time by this point but it's
also important to note that in this
point in the gospel John the Baptist was
also dead he's been killed by the
powerful Herod beheaded to fulfill the
whim of of herod's
daughter who do people say that I am
Jesus asks and the disciples answer um
someone great and kind of
dead it's obvious that their answers
were meant to kind of Dodge the question
because the fact is there were a lot of
people saying a lot of things about who
Jesus was and they were things that the
disciples would rather not
repeat things like blasphemer false
Prophet mad man so they give him this
little dodgy answer in hopes that it's
going to satisfy
them but see Jesus doesn't let it go he
looks at him at them and he sees them he
sees their anxieties he sees their fears
Jesus knows
them but he also knows what's ahead for
him and for his disciples so he looks
them straight in the eye and says but
who do you
say that I
am See Jesus is essentially telling that
it's important to know what others think
but when the rubber hits the road it
doesn't really matter what others think
it matters what you
think who do you say that I
am it's a pretty straightforward
question I mean one that I dare say most
of us here would be able to have a ready
answer for right especially sitting in
church on a Sunday evening surrounded by
our church
family we often affirmed together what
the apostles affirmed years ago that
Jesus is the son of God the Messiah Our
Savior the Lord the one who promises us
everything and gives up everything for
us we hear great pieces of music that
that Proclaim that Jesus is the king of
kings the Lord of lords and that he
shall reign forever and ever we sing of
his wondrous love that he has risen we
sing of walking and talking with him and
of how much he loves
us who do we say he
is well we know who Jesus is it's an
easy question with an easy
answer or is
it who do you say that I am not who the
apostles say I am
not who the hyw writers say that I am
not who my pastor or my friend says I
am who do
you say that I
am see the thing here is Jesus isn't
asking the disciples or us to list the
things we've heard about him he isn't
asking us to parot back what others have
written about him or believe him to be
he wants to know who I say he is
who each of you say he is it's a
personal question you see the question
no one else can
answer who do you say that I am who do
you know me to
be now this is a question that for many
years I believed I could avoid answering
I knew what others who you know what
others said about Jesus who they said
Jesus was and I believed it but I didn't
really know Jesus in a person way I
admired him I admired his love I I
admired his compassion I I admired his
ability to make others feel
worthy but I didn't really know
him one day I happened to pick up a book
by CS
Lewis and the book was called God in the
dark oh sorry God in the dock and as I
was leaping through it I came across
this passage and and it says here he
says I am trying to prevent anyone's
saying that really foolish thing that
people often people often say about
Jesus I'm ready to accept Jesus as a
great moral teacher but I don't accept
his claim to be
God this says Lewis is the one thing we
must not say a man who was merely a man
and said the sort of thing Jesus said
wouldn't be a great moral
teacher he'd be either a Lun lunatic on
a level with a man who says he's a
poached egg or else he'd be the devil of
hell you must make your choice Lewis
says either this man was and is the Son
of God or else a
Madman or something
worse well lewis' statement will it hit
me like a sledgehammer I'm telling you
right between the eyes and all of a
sudden I real I realized that I could no
longer just admire Jesus nor could I
could continue to rely on what others
said about
Jesus he is either who he said he is
or he's a
liar who do you think I
am I felt like Jesus was looking right
at me waiting for an answer and I wanted
to answer I really wanted to answer I
knew it was the most important question
I'd ever be asked but as I tried to
formulate an answer I realized I had no
idea I couldn't possibly
answer because I didn't
know my relationship you see with Jesus
was at best
superficial who do you say I am Jesus
says to me not just at church but who do
you say I am when when you're driving
home and someone cuts you off in traffic
who do you say I am when life hands you
a a terrible blow when a loved one is
suffering and everything seems to be
falling
apart who do you say I am when
confronted with racism or or um Justice
against lgtbq or anyone else who do you
say I am when hatred is
spewed who do you say I am amidst
political and ideological divisions in
our country who do you say I
am I got to tell you I can kind of
imagine the disciples looking like deer
in the headlights as Jesus asked the
questions because they're in the middle
of a city where Caesar is worshiped a
city where Outsiders and I can where
there where there are Outsiders and I
can kind of Imagine them thinking oh do
I have to answer can I think on it a
little bit I mean why would Jesus ask
him the question
there it's frightening and I imagine
they're a little afraid to get it
wrong so they stand there until Peter
wonderful impetuous Peter finally
answers you are the Messiah the Son of
God and Jesus looks at him and says
blessed are you Simon son of Jonah for
flesh and blood is not revealed this to
you but my Father in heaven and he says
and I tell you you are Peter on this
rock I will build my church and the
gates of Hades will not Prevail against
it now this passage is really
interesting to read in Greek because he
says and I tell you Jesus says you are
Peter Petro Rock and on this Petra Rock
I will build my church now the word that
is translated as church here is used by
Jesus only three times in the gospels
and it's all in the gospel of
Matthew this is the first time he uses
it the Greek word is ecclesium and it's
a compound of two Greek words e meaning
out from and to somewhere and C which
means to
call so ecclesium really means literally
to be called out from some place and
sent someplace
else on the rock that is Peter or the
foundation of Peter's declaration and
belief Jesus says I will build my church
I will build an assembly of those I call
out from and
send see we who
say
Jesus
is we who know who Jesus is
say
well we who don't know who Jesus is let
me Miss say said misspoke there we who
don't know what who Jesus is we don't
realize that what we say about him tells
about who we are and how we
are but it also tells about how we will
be and who we will be see it's a
statement of purpose a statement that
says we're willing to put our money
where our mouth
is I will build my church on this
Foundation Jesus says and the gates of
Hades will not Prevail against
it I'm sure many of you have probably
heard the scripture before and you've
probably heard it said slightly
differently on this rock I will build my
church and the Gates of Hell will not
Prevail against it but the word Jesus
uses here is not hell it's Hades and
it's a different meaning see Hades was a
gray place
a place where perhaps at least according
to Virgil a few favored Souls like the
emperor might find the alian fields of
happiness but most people good bad
indifferent well they in they expected
to spend eternity in Hades a vague
uncertain Place longing for life and the
sun see Hades is a place of
hopelessness and what Jesus is saying
here is that this hopelessness will not
Prevail against The Rock that is the
church now this imagery can of often
bring to mind the sort of Rock of
Gibralter right with high towers and
fortifications keeping Believers safe
and secure against the assaults of the
devil and his
minions but as Dr Blair uh D Dr Gary
Neil Hansen who is a blogger writes and
I'm paraphrasing this a bit
this is not about fortifying the church
against
attacks this is a statement about the
church in
Mission we are not soldiers defending a
holy church we are followers of the
Living God sent out to smash the gates
of hopelessness and despair to proclaim
a new kingdom a new way of living to
proclaim the love that God has for each
of us and the unconditional Grace that
that tells all they're
worthy they're loved they're important
they're needed and they're
wanted who do you say that I
am I'll tell you that faced with that
decision I had to decide what I was
going to do what I was going to say what
I was going to
believe and I decided I needed to find
out for myself
so I picked up my Bible who
knew and started
reading I read an chapter from the Old
Testament and a chapter from the New
Testament every
night and I'll tell you I got through
the New Testament about five times by
the time I got through the Old
Testament but by the time I was
finished I could answer that
question who do you say I am you are the
Messiah the Son of the Living God
our personal answer you see is key it's
key to who we really are and who we can
become but our answer doesn't stop with
us see our answer has a much larger
impact than just us who we say Jesus is
absolutely vital to the church as well
to what the church is now and what the
church can
become if we can say with Peter that
Jesus is the Messiah the Son of the
Living God well we must we must live
personal and corporate lives that are
reflective of that
belief and that's
hard that takes courage it takes courage
to follow Jesus it takes courage to
Proclaim with our very lives that we are
the church the body of
Christ and on this
rock prisoners are
freed on this rock the homeless are
howed Ed the hungry are
fed on this rock No One turns a blind
eye to
oppression on this rock swords are
beaten into plow shares and Spears into
pruning hooks on this rock there is no
place for racism or sexism or any other
kind of
isms on this rock there is no us or them
there's no left or right no political
parties or one-upsmanship
on this
rock
justice
prevails on this rock all are beloved
all are equally important and all are
welcome who do you say Jesus
is my friends our future depends on your
answer and it's churches like this
congregations like this who have the
opportunity to
Proclaim to Proclaim that good news to
stand up and say this is who Jesus
is Jesus is
Love Jesus is a person who eats with
Sinners and tax collectors Jesus says
come whoever you are
come I pray we'll take up the
challenge I pray we will
become that whom Jesus calls us to
be and I pray it in the name of the
father and of the son and of the holy
spirit
amen so it as a United Methodist Pastor
I do things a little bit differently
than I'm sure you guys are used to but I
will tell you right away that no matter
what church we were having communion at
this is an Open Table it's an open table
at any Methodist Church and it's an Open
Table I know at the table we believe
that this table belongs to Jesus Christ
not to any one church this is The Rock
right this is The Rock and everyone is
welcome here at this table so usually
when we do Holy Communion we talk a
little bit about confessing our sins
before we come to the table so I'd like
to invite everyone before we uh start
the Liturgy to have a moment of prayer
just confess your sins silently before
God merciful god we confess we've not
loved you with our whole
heart we confess we have failed to be an
obedient church we have not done your
will we've broken your law
we've rebelled against your love and
we've not loved our
neighbors we've not heard the Cry of the
needy in your mercy and in your grace we
ask you to forgive us oh
God to free us free us for joyful
obedience through Jesus Christ Our
Lord
amen he the good news Christ died for us
while we were yet sinners that proves
God's love for us and the name of Jesus
Christ you are forgiven and I am
forgiven glory to God
Amen so on the night in which our Lord
was the night before he was
betrayed our Lord took
bread he gave thanks to you oh God I'm
going put this over
here he gave thanks to you oh God he
broke the bread gave it to his disciples
and said Take and Eat This is my body
which is broken for you do this in
remembrance of
me and on the same night after the
supper was over he took the cup and he
gave thanks to you oh God he gave it to
his disciples and said drink from this
all of you this is my blood of the New
Covenant pour it out for the Forgiveness
of sins do this as often as you drink it
in remembrance of
me and so oh God in remembrance of these
your Mighty acts in Jesus Christ we
offer our elves in praise and
thanksgiving as a holy and Living
Sacrifice and Union with Christ's
offering for
us we ask you now to pour out your Holy
Spirit on us gathered here and on these
gifts of bread and wine make them be for
us the body and the blood of Christ that
we may be for the world the body of
Christ by your spirit make us one with
Christ one with each other and one in
Ministry to all the world until Christ
comes again in final Victory and we
Feast at his heavenly banquet it through
your son Jesus Christ in the Holy Spirit
and your holy church all honor and glory
is yours almighty God now and forever
more now with the confidence of children
of God I invite you to pray the prayer
Our Lord taught us to pray together Our
Father who art in heaven Hallowed be thy
name thy kingdom come thy will be done
on Earth as it is in heaven give us this
day our daily bread and forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against us and lead us not into
temptation but Deliver Us from Evil for
thine is the kingdom and the power and
the glory
forever
amen because there is one loaf we who
are
many We Are One the loaf the bread from
which we all partake is a sharing in the
body of Christ and the cup over which we
give thanks is a sharing in the blood of
Christ I invite you to come as the
spirit moves you and we will have uh the
bread in the front here I'll serve the
bread and then we have the wine will be
served on either side the white is grape
juice am I correct and the red is and
the red is wine so come come to the
table you're welcome
here
[Music]
let us
pray Eternal God we give you thanks for
this holy
mystery this mystery in which you have
given yourself to us we Grant now oh God
that we may go out into the world in the
strength of your spirit to give
ourselves for others in the name of
Jesus Christ Our Lord we
pray
amen thank you so much Pastor Denise so
glad you with us tonight if you guys
would stand as we close the service out
with this kind of benediction song
[Music]
um I don't want to
go Christ be
and my heart aches with sorrow as I hit
the
road Christ be with me when the care of
my family takes all that I have Christ
within me when I born and exhausted the
shame that I'm m chist
defend
me I Rise up today in a strength that is
not my
[Music]
own I'm held by the prise of God that
I'm never
alone when I'm TOS to the
and I want to give up Christ
beide when I'm breaking my back and it's
never
enough Christ
[Music]
beide
me I Rise up today in a strength that is
not my own
I held by the promise of God that I'm
never
[Music]
alone when I work hard but someone else
gets the
reward
CR I see me and I ask for promotion and
they shut the
door God
ears hear
[Music]
me I Rise up today in a strength that is
not my
own and I'm held by the prise of God
that I'm never
alone when I CL the first steps toward
long H dream
Christ above me when IAP out in faith
and I hope to find Wings Christ
be
[Music]
me
so thank you all so much for joining us
this
evening if you're new we would love to
hear from you so you can fill out a card
on the table over here to the right and
drop it into the little box or you can
scan the QR code on the screen and fill
out a online visitor's card so that will
allow us to follow up with you and to
answer any questions that you might have
and to say thank you for visiting now
don't forget to RSVP for the welcome to
the table class which is next week if
you're interested in becoming a member
at the table or just want to learn more
about us um also my name is johnine so
if you are in need of prayer a hug or
just any kind of General support I would
like to be here for you so come and find
me after the service
here at the table we're committed to
creating an inclusive Christ centered
community that touches lives and
generosity is a key component of that
mission so if you'd like to join us in
supporting this work financially again
you can scan the QR code on the screen
or out in the little table over here to
the right uh you can make a donation or
you can go to the website at theable
tx.org
[Music]
all right now it's time that I send you
into your week with this blessing so you
can hold out your hands in a posture of
receiving or you can just open up your
hearts to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of God this this is
true on your best day and it's true on
your worst day so as you go out into
your week ahead and it's yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy you
are accepted just as you are and go
filled with God's holy spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts and
Graces and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact
with be blessed have a good week we hope
to see you back here next Sunday good
[Music]
night I Rise up today in a strength that
is not my
own
I'm held by the promise of God that I'm
never alone I Rise
up I Rise up today in a strength that is
not my
own I held by the prom of God that I'm
never
alone
when I climb the first step toward a
long H dream chist
Ser me I leap out in faith and I hope to
find a Wings Christ
beath
[Music]
me
uh